With a run time clocking in at over three
hours, it might be easier to explain what
doesn't happen in Avengers: Endgame instead
of what does.
For instance, fans don't get bored.
Fans don't get up to use the bathroom.
And fans don't ever want it to end.
But it did end and we're here to explain what
that ending was all about.
Here's the ending of Avengers: Endgame explained...with
lots of spoilers ahead.
After returning from their various missions
to different past moments from the history
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe, the Avengers
grouped back up with the six infinity stones
in tow.
But Black Widow was missing, as she sacrificed
herself to retrieve the Soul Stone.
It all goes down in a scene that mirrored
the death of Gamora in Avengers: Infinity
War.
The new and improved Professor Hulk who has
the combined might of the Hulk with the intellect
of Bruce Banner used the recreated Infinity
Gauntlet to reverse Thanos' snap, bringing
back all the people who were erased from existence
in Avengers: Infinity War.
But though he tried, it couldn't return Natasha
to life.
It may seem weird that a guy with an all-powerful
wishing glove still couldn't undo this one
major death.
But Black Widow's absence at the end of the
film proves that the Infinity Stones aren't
quite as infinite as their name would suggest.
Of course, that doesn't mean our heroes can't
find a way to pluck her out of the past and
send her...
"BACK TO THE FUTURE!"
Okay, so here’s where things get weird.
On their trip back to 2014 to get the Power
Stone seen in the beginning of Guardians of
the Galaxy our timeline's Nebula was captured
by Thanos, who secretly replaced her with
the evil 2014 version of Nebula.
Having infiltrated the Avengers headquarters,
evil Nebula then summoned 2014 Thanos and
his armies using the time machine.
They blew everything up, with evil Nebula
getting ahold of the new Infinity Gauntlet
in a callback to the original comics.
But then the good Nebula from the real timeline
shot her younger evil self stone dead.
Luckily, this didn't affect the good Nebula
at all.
So what does that mean?
It proves our heroes' pasts can't be changed
and that alternate universes are probably
something the MCU is going to need to sort
out in Phase 4.
With the Infinity Gauntlet once again in play,
the Avengers fought Thanos to a standstill,
including an absolutely epic sequence where
Captain America gained the powers of Thor
by wielding the mystic hammer Mjonir
to deliver a massive whooping, something which
was first teased way back in Avengers: Age
of Ultron.
Still, Thanos eventually called in the cavalry
by which we mean the intergalactic horde of
creeps we saw back in Avengers: Infinity War.
Luckily, the Hulk's reverse snap had also
restored all the dusted heroes from Avengers:
Infinity War.
Just as Captain America was about to face
the armies of Thanos alone again echoing a
classic moment from the comics all the dead
heroes arrived via Doctor Strange's magic
portals in a scene reminiscent of the end
of Ready Player One.
Only… better.
Plus, the arrival of all the heroes allowed
Captain America to finally deliver the team’s
signature catchphrase from the comics, "Avengers
Assemble!," something fans have been waiting
for for the last decade, especially after
Marvel did a fakeout tease at the end of Age
of Ultron.
"Avengers…"
In the end, you knew it had to come down to
Tony Stark versus Thanos for the fate of the
universe.
After all, the showdown had been teased way
back in Avengers: Age of Ultron.
And luckily, Tony was clued in to his big
chance because Doctor Strange was there to
give him the finger.
No, not that finger just an index finger to
note that this was the one chance in 14 million
for victory that he had foreseen in Avengers:
Infinity War.
Stark didn't disappoint, taking the Infinity
Stones from Thanos and using it to snap the
big purple meanie out of existence along with
all his minions.
We learned in Guardians of the Galaxy that
mere mortals cannot harness the power of the
Infinity Stones, though.
Fulfilling that cosmic promise, the strain
was too much for Tony.
He died a hero, and was given a hero's funeral
attended by everyone who was anyone, including
Nick Fury and even that kid from Iron Man
3.
As for why it had to be Tony who saved the
day and bit the dust well, he's the guy who
started the whole MCU back with the first
Iron Man movie.
He's been the heart and soul of the franchise,
and without Tony making the ultimate sacrifice
to save the universe, it just wouldn't feel
right.
He may be gone, but he'll never be forgotten.
"I am Iron Man."
Following Tony’s funeral, Captain America
was tasked with returning the Infinity Stones
to their proper places in time, in order to
ensure that no more alternate universes were
created.
But in a big twist, Cap decided not to come
back from his time travel jaunt.
Instead, he returned to the 1940s so he could
finally have that dance he promised Peggy
Carter back in Captain America: The First
Avenger.
And then he stayed there, apparently marrying
her and living a long and full life.
"Peggy."
"I'm going to need a raincheck on that dance."
"Alright.
A week next Saturday, at the Stork Club."
So Steve Rogers, at least, got a happy ending.
And so did his buddy Sam Wilson, a.k.a.
The Falcon.
Not only was he brought back to life, but
an old Steve Rogers still spry at well over
100 turned up to present Sam with his indestructible
shield and the charge to carry on as the new
Captain America — a development that also
took place in the comics several years ago.
Tony and Steve might be gone, but one of the
Big Three may apparently still be moving forward
in the MCU.
After wallowing in self-pity throughout the
whole film, Thor finally seemed to get his
act together at the very end and decided to
head into space with the Guardians of the
Galaxy, leaving Valkyrie behind as the new
leader of the Asgardians.
We also got a hint of what we might see when
Thor and the Asgardians of the Galaxy return
in Guardians of the Galaxy vol. 3, as their
final scene showed Peter Quill searching for
the location of the 2014 version of Gamora,
who came through the portal with Thanos...but
vanished after the final battle.
But that's just one of several loose ends
Marvel will have to tie up in future movies...
We won't have long to wait to see the fallout
from Avengers: Endgame, as the teasers for
Spider-man: Far From Home suggest Peter Parker
and Happy Hogan will be dealing in very different
ways with the loss of Tony Stark.
They aren't the only ones with things to work
through though.
After stealing the Tesseract again Loki got
a second chance at life that seems likely
to be explored in the upcoming Loki series
on Disney's new streaming service, Disney+.
Likewise, Hawkeye has his family back, which
is likely to be explored in the upcoming Hawkeye
series on the same service.
Meanwhile, Wakanda suddenly has its king back
again.
That's probably one king too many, though,
because whoever's been running the show for
the last five years in T'Challa's absence
M'Baku maybe? might not want to just hand
the throne back over.
And then there's Black Widow, who has a solo
film in development even though she's dead.
Will the heroes rebuild a time machine to
bring her back?
Will the film be a prequel?
Will we find out she was a Life Model Decoy
the whole time?
So many possibilities...
All told, the Avengers saved a lot of lives
and won the day.
But that was the easy part.
Picking up the pieces is likely to be the
hard part.
And we can't wait for Phase 4 to begin so
we can see just how they do it.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.